she's back and when it come you may
remember as a conservative home office
Minister is standing for Nigel Farage's
brexit party if the European elections
take place welcome to you indeed well
I've got to put you I mean you want to
know deal breaks it Stephen get things
here saying that would be very
deleterious economically and of course
I'd have loved to deal but we haven't
got a deal and the fact is that we did
go back to the EU the only thing that
Parliament finally did agree on which
was that we would have the may
withdrawal deal as long as there were
legally binding assurances on the
backstop Clawd youngster says no go away
we're not going to do that so we meekly
go away and we are in a complete mess
and what worries me is I think there is
a growing disengagement now let me
finish this sentence Adam then over to
you there's a growing disengagement
between the people and Parliament but is
it worth doing something that is going
to cost jobs and cost businesses in this
country if mr. Gethin is right that's a
very big if because first of all we were
told during project fear that merely
voting to leave the EU was going to
bring back economic Armageddon the
economy is doing very nicely thank you
the official figures say the economy has
not grown at a rate it would have grown
nevertheless it is growing and
nevertheless we have record levels of
low unemployment so don't tell me that
we suffered as we were promised that we
would buy Cameron and özil no but it's
all part of that there are always going
to be predictions of doom tomorrow if we
do X Y Z we've just got to have the
courage of our convictions but I'm not
quite sure why we're debating no deal
because Parliament's taken that off the
table what do you think it has well it
has in legal dress I mean the reason why
I was asking about it because as I
understand it that is the brexit party's
policy that you want to leave without a
deal as soon as possible we'd rather
leave with no deal than with a bad deal
we're discussing it that's what you're
going to be standing on we got an offer
at the moment is a bad deal so obviously
we would prefer no deal to that but if
there were to be a deal between now and
the European elections which somehow I
doubt given the rate of progress so far
you know I'm sure we would look at that
on its merits but what we want
crucially Adam is to leave in a
meaningful sense not one leg in one leg
you was he difficult for you to leave
the Conservative Party yes of course it
was I mean I first voted for the
Conservative Party when I was 21 if you
had to wait that long in those days and
I'm now 71 so for half a century I've
been voting supporting campaigning
representing the Conservative Party of
course it was difficult and why did you
do
because Britain's a laughingstock
internationally because Parliament is
beyond parody because both major parties
are busy turning away from manifestos on
which they were elected which was to
deliver brexit and above all because the
nation is thoroughly fed up and wants an
end and I believe that if in the
European elections we sent our real
seismic shock to both major parties
labour Heartland and Tory shires
they will start to take it seriously you
also say that Theresa Mays quotes are
hopelessly inadequate she's I'm sorry to
say it but she is and I mean you know I
I've put it an even stronger terms than
that at and I said that she's the worst
Prime Minister we've had since and me
but then I think that we've got the
worst leader of the Opposition in the
entire history of the Labour Party and
the worst Parliament since Oliver
Cromwell just so that I so if there was
a change of leader would you sort of go
back to the tourist you know not unless
we're going to have a proper brexit I
mean I I'm not joining the brexit party
just because I'm fed up I'm joining it
because I want a proper brexit I want us
to leave and to be able to take control
of our own borders our own laws our own
trade deals now none of that means
staying with one foot in I mean you're
likening your move to breaks it from the
Conservatives to your earlier move from
the Church of England to the Church of
Rome the Roman Catholic Church that that
makes Nigel Farage the Pope doesn't it
no as I as I've said this morning on
several media you know I think brexit is
mighty important but it's not going to
impact on my immortal soul you don't
think so no but do you think due to your
fame in fact when it comes to break
city's Faraj to the Pope oh don't be
silly
what for Rogers is the man who against
all the odds and from outside
Westminster has managed to carry his
program through so that we don't like
well he's not going to become Prime
Minister what I want is an overwhelming
and overwhelming brexit victory on May
the 23rd we've sat what I want we've
seen you on Strictly Come Dancing and
other panel shows and celebrity shows
does that mean just of a serious
politician well people will have to
judge that by what I've been saying but
don't imagine for a moment that I
haven't been commenting politically I
may not have done your program Adam
couldn't invite me to but I've done many
other political programs and I write
every week for the daily exposure I call
him every Wednesday that is the last
word that's all from all that politics
for today do join us tomorrow